[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire après les graves accusations
contre le groupe orpea paru dans le
livre les fossoyeurs de victor castanet
c'est tout le business lucratif des
ehpad privé qui se retrouve sur la
sellette les actions du groupe korian et
de hélène la santé sont en forte baisse
mais les personnes âgées dépendantes
sont elles beaucoup mieux lotis dans les
ehpad publics et quelle est la
responsabilité de l'état dans un système
qui a été si souvent dénoncée et jamais
véritablement réformer bref faut-il
raser les ehpad pour en débattre nous
avons invité les richards vous êtes
journaliste indépendante vous réalisez
depuis 12 ans des reportages pour des
émissions comme envoyé spécial sur
france 2 zone interdite sur m6 où le doc
du dimanche sur france 5 et vous venez
de publier en septembre cessons de
maltraiter nos vieux aux éditions du
rocher 3 ans dans kent dans les ehpad et
à domicile où est le problème à votre
avis le problème en fait s'il résulte
d'un sous-financement on peut dire
globale du secteur de la dépendance
c'est vrai que là on est très focalisés
sur le secteur privé lucratif mais il ya
également énormément de maltraitance
institutionnelle dans tous les
établissements qu'ils soient publics
associatifs ou privés
et ce essentiellement par un manque de
moyens humains un manque de personnel
dans les rideaux je vous êtes première
vice présidente du département de la
vienne en charge des personnes âgées et
des personnes handicapées une partie du
financement des ehpad publics et privés
et de la responsabilité des départements
il faut le savoir
le premier financeur public c'est la
sécurité sociale le deuxième c'est le
département pour vous et le problème
bonjour à tous bonjour à tous pour moi
le problème est la difficulté du nombre
de gestionnaires et de manque de
lisibilité et de possibilités de
d'avoir une fiche très clair
où on est quand même pieds poings liés
tout en étant financeurs
michel billé vous êtes sociologue
spécialisé dans les questions de
vieillesse et de handicap président de
l'union internationale des instances et
office d de retraite et personnes âgées
membre du comité scientifique de
l'observatoire de l'âgisme vous avez
signé ou cosigné plusieurs ouvrages sur
la vieillesse dont un dictionnaire
impertinent de lièvre de la vieillesse
et puis il ya également dépendance quand
tu nous tiens les deux sont parus chez
rs pour vous un problème
pour moi le problème il est que nous
citoyens concitoyens nous nous
accommodons depuis fort longtemps des
situations
construites par une logique gestionnaire
une logique de management une logique
néolibérale qui nous invite nous incite
à croire que l'on pourrait faire mieux
et dépenser moins absurde
damien le guay vous êtes philosophe vous
enseigner l'éthique de fans vie vous
êtes membre de l'association de soin
palliatif et vous êtes auteur de quand
l'euthanasie sera là qui vient juste de
paraître aux éditions salvator pour vous
où est le problème
il y en a 3 si vous voulez qui
s'empilent les uns dans les autres le
premier c'est le regard négatif que nous
avons sur le vieil âge à partir du
moment où on est en dehors de la vie
active qu'est ton sinon pas grand chose
deuxième problème
l'hypocrisie de l'état
au mans par là mais quand j'entends la
ministre effectivement poussé des cris
d'orfraie alors qu'elle est aux
commandes et alors que depuis 15 ans ou
20 ans qu'un tous les rapports ont été
posés sur la table et rien n'a été fait
et troisième problème c'est qu'ils me
semble que les ehpad sont de plus en
plus des lieux incertain c'est à dire
qu'ils sont à la fois des hôtels où les
gens résident est à la fois des hôpitaux
et entre les deux plus tout le reste des
lieux d'animation ha ha et pour prendre
en charge tout cela
on a une difficulté structurelle pour
effectivement essayé de mettre ensemble
tout cela est donc ça rejaillit
forcément sur la qualité qui est un vrai
problème alors commençons par comme par
la responsabilité des collectivités
publiques
l'état peut-il quand on voit tout ce
qu'on a pu dire sur orpea mais aussi ce
qu'on va dire sur le reste du spectateur
privé l'état peut-il se dégager de toute
responsabilité
non en fait il ya deux choses c'est vrai
que sur le l'aspect privé lucratif et
dans ce qui est dénoncé par le livre de
victor castanet et à l'organisation le
système mis en place par orpea qui
consiste à faire du profit en rationnant
aussi bien les repas que les protections
et aussi en faisant des économies sur la
masse salariale donc ça c'est des choses
effectivement qui étaient déjà connus
qui se sont dénoncés depuis des années
il ya eu plusieurs livres et de
reportages donc c'est vrai que les
pouvoirs publics ne peuvent pas ignorer
et feindre d'ignorer ce problème c'est
quelque chose qui était connue après là
ça a été démontré de manière très
méticuleuse et très approfondies en
décortiquant vraiment le système et
l'industrialisation tel qu'il le dit
voilà de
2,2 de la dépendance
mais les pouvoirs publics ne sont pas
sont aussi responsables si vous voulez
dans le sens où en effet il ya un
problème donc comme je le faisais de
maltraitance institutionnelle au delà du
fait que la masse salariale soit réduite
dans les établissements privés lucratifs
dans certains grands groupes du fait que
ce sont les pouvoirs publics qui
financent tous les postes de soignants
donc forcément on part déjà avec un taux
en deçà du taux minimum qu'il devrait y
avoir c'est à dire que selon la
défenseuse des droits que l'arrêt dont
il faudrait un ratio minimum de 80
personnels % résident aujourd'hui en
moyenne tout est pas de confondues on
est à 63 % résident donc de toute façon
il ya pour être plus exact je crois
qu'on est à -6 pour 10 soit moins 60 %
dans le privé est à moi 70% dans le plus
et ça veut dire qu'il ya encore moins de
personnel dans le privé lucratif mais en
moyenne voilà on est à 6 pour 10
millions quand même fou parce qu'on paye
plus cher dans le privé exactement 10
ans s'attend à voir plus un meilleur
accompagnement ce qui n'est pas le cas
quand on fait donc il ya de toute façon
un problème un déficit structurel en
fait de personnel qui créé voilà ce
qu'on appelle la maltraitance
institutionnelle et qui est exacerbée
dans le privé luc dans certains grands
groupes du privé lucratif par des
économies qui se rajoutent justement sur
et c'est d'économiser des postes en ne
remplaçant pas certains congés certains
arrêts maladie etc ce qui aggrave
d'autant plus le problème venez donc je
voulais vous êtes d'accord
oui je suis d'accord avec ce que vient
de dire madame
moi je voudrais dire que l'état fait des
effets d'annoncé et qui sont souvent pas
suivies d'effet sans concertation avec
les départements alors je vais parler de
la vienne puisque j'excuse élu et je
connais bien mon territoire et je
connais je rencontre très régulièrement
les directeurs et directrices des parts
de départements de d'établissement
pardon et ceux qui la composent
j'échange beaucoup avec les
professionnels
aujourd'hui on nous propose par exemple
sur le domicile à renens 43
derrière il ya une compensation de
l'état mais qui est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux derrière les départements
accomplissent complètement leur vocation
qui leur est confiée sur sur les
solidarités mais on a un manque crucial
de compensation de l'état qui met à mal
les budgets du département
sur sur le volet formation j'étais
encore cet après midi avec les
directeurs
d'établissements pour personnes
handicapées qui est très prochain de la
dépendance est aussi crié très haut et
très fort le désarroi des salariés par
rapport à la revalorisation des salaires
l'avenant 43 pour les domiciles c'est
bien ça permet de renforcer personnes
sur des postes mais ça ne crée pas des
postes il faut arriver à susciter des
vocations est arrivé à
former ses personnels ou sein des
établissements parce que on a angers les
témoignages de directeur d'ehpad et
arrive à fermer des lits parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le personnel qu'ils ont face
qu'on soit bien d'accord en manque de
moyens donc au manque de personnel et
quand on manque de personnel forcément
il ya de la maltraitance à la clé qui
n'est pas volontaire bien entendu mais
qui est simplement parce que quand on
n'a pas le temps de s'occuper des gens
maraussan de cuques mal et les gens en
souffrent un êtes d'accord michel billé
complètement d'accord et on maltraite à
ce moment là les personnes accueillies
âgées handicapées on maltraite
évidemment le personnel qui ne peut pas
travailler dans de bonnes conditions et
on maltraite parfois même l'encadrement
qui se trouve lui aussi confronté à des
situations qu'ils ne voudraient pas
vivre pour moi vraiment la maltraitance
institutionnelle à ce paradoxe de
maltraiter tout ce qui compose la
situation que l'on regarde vous pouvez
ajouter aussi les familles des gens qui
se retrouvent dans ces ehpad parce qu'à
prier vide quand ils confient leurs
parents un établissement de la sorte ça
n'est pas pour qu'on leur rationnent les
couches qu'on leur compte le temps et
qu'on les nourrisse mal évidemment et il
me paraît clair que si le livre
les fossoyeurs eux reconnaît aujourd'hui
un tel écho alors que quelques ouvrages
précédents semblant avoir connu un peu
moins et pourtant disait des choses tout
à fait sur le même registre il me semble
que la crise qu'ovide vient en quelque
sorte braquer le projecteur sur la
réalité que l'on essaie de d'observer et
les familles ont tellement été
confrontés à des situations
insupportables
invivable pendant cette période qu vide
que évidemment rien n'est supportable
aujourd'hui et que du coup le le manque
de moyens des ehpad par exemple apparaît
de façon absolument honteuse
mais alors comment expliquer damien le
guay
le le comportement alors de nous
dirigeants des gouvernements pas
forcément de celui-ci de tous les
gouvernements qui se sont succédé à
priori c'est à dire cette indifférence
totale il ya eu des rapports j'en ai eu
beaucoup un
certain nombre ont été cités récemment
je crois qu'il y en a eu sept
rien qu'au cours des quatre dernières
années pour nous dire attention
attention attention attention le tas ne
fait rien mais à la limite on pourrait
dire les contribuables non plus j'ai pas
entendu beaucoup de gens dire il
faudrait qu'on nous payer plus d'impôts
éventuellement plus de cotisations pour
que les les personnes âgées se soient
mieux traités
si vous voulez moi je crois qu'il ya
deux choses à travers ce qu'il faut pas
se tromper de débat quand on parle de
maltraitance institutionnelle
la question c'est de savoir d'où vient
cette maltraitance institutionnelle qui
est responsable derrière ce que nous
constatons et qui est abominable qui est
responsable de cela est évidemment
forcément on voit bien que 1 dans la
question du soin c'est à dire combien
faut-il mettre de budget pour que les
soignants soient présents en nombre
suffisant dans les ehpad c'est l'état
combien faut-il mettre d'argent sur la
table j'ai lu je suis passé de la
question mais j'ai lu qu'il fallait 10
milliards de plus pour répondre
effectivement la question comme vous
l'avait dit il ya eu rapport sur rapport
il ya eu depuis 15 ans 20 ans à chaque
fois qu'un président de république le
président hollande le président sarkozy
avant hollande et macro ont toujours dit
qu'il voulait absolument régler cette
question là quand il fait rien donc ça
c'est la première chose et quand
j'entends madame bourguignon dit le
grand âge ne s'invite pas dans le débat
public
qu'à londres des crises autrement ils
peinent à intéresser je me dis mais j'ai
pas qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle est
ministre de quoi sinon de cela et s'il
n'a pas réussi à imposer son sujet comme
étant un sujet prioritaire je sais pas
faut faire autre chose parce que à ce
moment là ça veut dire qu'on ne peut pas
d'une part
monté sur ses grands chevaux considérer
que des scandales partout alors qu'on
est en charge de la question alors qu'on
ne contrôle pas parce qu'effectivement
un des problèmes c'est que les contrôles
qui sont faits sont d'une part annoncé
et deuxièmement si j'ai bien compris en
très petit nombre pourquoi tout cela
n'at-il pas fait pourquoi est ce que
monsieur lune ibo président du haut du
haut conseil du financement de la
protection sociale je lisais je le
disais ça c'est maintenant les journaux
amis un rapport a remis un rapport en
2019 où ils l'appelaient à prendre des
mesures énergiques pour sortir cette
question là rien n'a été fait donc un
moment donné il faut dire la question
elle est prioritaire il faut l'imposer à
l'agenda politique que les politiques
eux-mêmes se saisisse de cette question
là plutôt que de faire rapport sur
rapport et éviter de considérer que la
maltraitance institutionnelle comme je
l'entends depuis quelques temps elle est
liée seulement où se réveiller seulement
aux ehpad privée donc au capitalisme
alors que quand on regarde ce que j'ai
fait
on regarde les dépôts de plainte ou les
réclamations quand des fêtes récemment
donc sur les neuf mille réclamations
quand on fait 50 % sont pour le secteur
public 30% pour les ehpad en lucratif et
20% pour les ehpad privé ce qui
correspond exactement à la répartition
actuelle des ehpad donc la question ne
semble t-il elle est bien au niveau 2 du
politique de la responsabilité politique
de ce qu'il faut effectivement prendre
en charge pour régler cette question là
et faire en sorte que nos vieux nos
anciens soient soignés et pris en charge
comme il se doit et lise richard vous
qui avait enquêté longuement sur les
ehpad on sait qu'en ce moment depuis que
la parution du livre de victor castanet
le gouvernement a pas du tout envie que
toute cette histoire leur mais retombe
dessus 1 il faut très attention et on
peut dieu quand on entend les débats
houleux dans la presse pour l'instant on
est vraiment sur les ehpad privé c'est
les méchants pour l'instant ça se passe
bien ok mais mais comment expliquez vous
le fait qu'il n'ait jamais réagi aurait
dû se douter qu'un jour ça leur tombera
dessus et effectivement on se dit
pourquoi n'ont ils rien fait les uns
derrière les autres là je me demande si
c'est pas parce que après tout dans les
sondages on voit que les électeurs se
soucie de la sécurité alors on n'arrête
pas de nous parler de la police il
suffirait que les électeurs disent on se
soucie les personnes âgées pour que tout
à coup l'argent tombe sur les ehpad ou
est ce qu'il ya une totale indifférence
oui je pense qu'en effet la période
électorale joue beaucoup dans les
réactions politiques actuelles et je
pense aussi qu en effet comme c'est un
groupe privé lucratif qui est visé ça
arrange bien le gouvernement en fait
d'eux de se défausser un petit peu
justement de ce problème là mais ce
qu'il faut quand même rappeler c'est
qu'il y avait une loi une loi grande la
loi grand âge et autonomie qui devait
voir le jour elle a été enterrée par le
gouvernement alors que c'était une
promesse justement du président et c'est
ça qui est dramatique c'est à dire que
comme vous l'avait dit il ya eu tout un
tas de rapports on sait exactement ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour améliorer le
recteur libolo du soir il y en a eu tout
un tas successifs voilà de très grande
qualité on sait qu'il faut environ voilà
dix milliards d'euros donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya aussi un financement mais la
question de la deux du vieillissement
elle est primordiale parce qu'on va tous
devenir vieux l'espérance de vie
s'allonge et donc il faut absolument que
les politiques justement agissent dès
maintenant et cesse de reporter en fait
cette question-là aux calendes grecques
comme ils le font depuis des années et
l'enterrement de cette loi grand âge
elle est vraiment le reflet voilà du
fait que finalement les vieux ça
n'intéresse pas
c'est une forme d'agissements en fait
qui est lié en fait c'est une
discrimination en raison de l'âge et qui
est parfois inconsciente et qui est
présente à la fois donc dans la société
tout entière séviront quelque chose
qu'on veut pas trop voir la vieillesse
ça on voit à la mort à la finitude etc
et c'est aussi quelque chose qui est
très présent chez les ch et les
politiques puisque depuis des années la
question est sans cesse reportée valérie
d'auge
vous êtes d'accord c'est pas seulement
au fond si l'état s'en fout c'est parce
que les électeurs s'en foutent
je partage les propos de madame je
regrette que l approche des élections
présidentielles
aucun candidat ne s'emparent de cette
thématique
on a entendu sur les dernières élections
que nous venons d'avoir élections
départementales élections régionales à
laquelle j'ai été j'ai été réélu
pour être maman d'une dune adultes en
situation de handicap je peux vous dire
que ces sujets ont intéressé là à la
période des élections je me suis réjoui
un que c'est ce que ces questions
intéressent mais quelque part ce que je
dis beaucoup aux gens c'est que ça
brille pas et
les gens partent du principe que oui
effectivement c'est ces gens ne votent
pas donc on va se désintéresser et je
trouve ça regrettable parce que les baby
boomers en 2026 ils vont commencer à
avoir 80 ans donc moi je suis quelqu'un
qui qui suis une personne de coeur
qu'aiment les gens et j'aime bien
procéder par par anticipation et être
visionnaire et c'est la raison pour
laquelle en commission permanente la
semaine dernière
j'ai été un peu provocatrice
effectivement en disant que l'état se
désintéresser des personnes âgées ne
voulait pas
extension de places d'ehpad oui le
directeur de l'agencé régionale de santé
nouvelle aquitaine me l'a clairement dit
en disant non c'est le domicile alors le
domicile à outrance non je suis pas
d'accord c'est comme l'inclusion pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
il faut de la place pour tout le monde
il faut un panel d'offres mais on ne
peut pas être sectaire en proposant que
le domicile les gens à domicile font
bien sûr de belles choses et je voudrais
en profiter pour rendre hommage à tous
les professionnels parce que c'est vrai
que cette période est compliquée pour
eux faut pas stigmatiser mais derrière
il ya eu de belles choses de bel élan de
solidarité qui ont été faites pendant
cette créé crise sanitaire mais pas que
ils ont été au front et d'être encore
pointé du doigt ça crée des malaises et
et ce soir je voudrais leur rendre
hommage à toutes et à tous pour le
travail qu'ils font au quotidien
chhabiyé
oui on évoquait tout à l'heure le regard
négatif porté sur la vieillesse
il me semble que on tient là un élément
fondamental non la vieillesse n'est pas
une maladie elle est une chance je
vieillis ce qui me donne la chance de
connaître mes petits-enfants et 6 qui
leur donne a eu la chance d'avoir un
grand père et pas n'importe lequel vous
vous en doutez bref ma vieillesse elle
est une chance pour moi bien sûr mais
elle est une chance pour l'autre non les
vieux sont pas une charge certainement
pas les vieux sont une chance ici je
regarde cela comme ça alors la dépense
même très importante que la collectivité
publique doit faire pour accueillir
accompagner
soigner aider soutenir ceux qui
vieillissent cette dépense là nous
n'avons plus à la considérer comme une
charge il nous faut la considérer comme
un investissement
un investissement incroyablement porter
alors porteur d'emplois j'aime bien
mettre au point la formule l'argent pour
les vieux
c'est l'emploi des jeunes et ben voilà
donc un investissement porteur d'emplois
pour les jeunes encore faut-il que cet
emploi soit de qualité on pourra y
revenir mais vraiment porteur d'emplois
porteurs d'échangés économiques porteurs
des chances culturels porteurs des
chances d'affectif autrement dit porteur
de cette formidable aventure que nous
pouvons avoir à rencontrer faire se
rencontrer les générations
si nous regardons
l'argent consacré comme un
investissement porteur au lieu de le
regarder comme une charge alors nous ne
parlerons plus de réduire
l'investissement
ce serait dramatique
mais au contraire peut-être même de
l'augmenter pour que ils produisent
demain davantage des changes sur tous
les registres que j'ai essayé de situer
quant au départ de la crise de côte du
col vides le gouvernement était très
prompte à fermer les ehpad tout à coup
les familles n'ont plus pu rendre visite
alors alors aux membres de leur famille
qui s'y trouvaient on les a isolés il
fallait surtout pas que les gens dans
les ehpad meurt à quoi on a répondu mais
dans les ehpad les gens meurent même
naturellement avant même le coc vide on
a même dit qu'il n'avait qu'une
espérance de vie très limitée dans les
ehpad maintenant que l'on sait de plus
intéressé autres ehpad on comprend
peut-être pourquoi d'ailleurs on y
survit pas beaucoup plus d'un an et demi
mais j'exagère peut-être mais je crois
que c'est le chiffre qu'on avait donné
toujours est il que là aussi on voit
tout à coup les les personnes résidentes
dans les ehpad était absolument sacré
pendant la crise du coc vide il fallait
absolument les les sauver de toutes les
maladies et et puis après on s'aperçoit
qu'au fond on s'en fout c'est quand même
bizarre damien le guay
ce qui est bizarre c'est vous laisser
deux choses la première c'est que moi je
trouve que je suis intervenu en 2020
dans le figaro sur arte dans les médias
pour dire effectivement que cet
isolement cet isolement des personnes
âgées dans les ehpad et est une raison
supplémentaire pour elles ces personnes
âgées de désespérer quand on est dans
ces situations là le grand âge comment
vit-on quelles sont les raisons
d'espérer de vivre de se ressourcer
sinon le contact que l'on a avec ses
voisins ses voisines avec sa famille
pour être effectivement une ressource
pour tout le monde coupé
tous ses liens avec les personnes de
l'extérieur faire en sorte qu
effectivement les personnes restent
âgées restent tout seuls dans leur
chambre c'est une façon de les faire
mourir à petit feu et de leurs 2 et de
couper toutes les raisons pour
lesquelles elles doivent ou peuvent
vivre je trouve qu'il y avait quelque
chose qui était une forme de dictature
au sens romain de la raison hygiénique
qui préservait les corps et supprimer
les raisons de vivre et je trouve que
cette politique là était effectivement
calamiteuse de sorte que effectivement
dans les ehpad ou dans les pouilles où
les personnes âgées vivent pour une
partie papa pour eux pour porto pour
tous mpt enfin pour une partie cette
politique là a été effectivement
complètement dingue si je peux me
permettre l'expression mais dingue voilà
donc je trouve que là ya effectivement
une vraie une vraie responsabilité qu'il
faut effectivement pointé du doigt alors
après la question qui se pose c'est
qu'est ce que l'on fait ne c est pas de
là comment est-ce que d'une façon ou
d'une autre on est susceptible de
revitaliser de redonner remettre au
centre comme comme le disait monsieur
billets remettre au centre les vieux de
la cité plutôt que soit 200 délaissé
soin de les mettre aux périphéries des
villes soit de les laisser entre eux
pour qu'ils puissent vivre leur vie tout
seul sans être au centre ou au milieu de
la cité et donc je crois
qu'effectivement quelque chose qui
interroge le regard que nous portons sur
les personnes âgées de sorte que on peut
craindre que cet isolement de plus en
plus grand des personnes âgées ce
confinement institutionnels et personnes
âgées dans des lieux qui leur est
consacrée
ne soit une façon de retourner à toute
façon le stigmate de l'âge contre elle
oui et donc ce retournement du stigmate
con elle les amène à effectivement avoir
une vie là bas qui n'est pas au maximum
de leurs de leur vigueur intellectuelle
et de leur vigueur de vie pour employer
un euphémisme on fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
faut-il faut-il raser les ehpad c'est la
question qu'on se pose avec élise
richard qu'un journaliste et qui a
publié en septembre dernier c'est son de
maltraiter nos vieux avec valérie d'auge
qui est la première vice présidente du
département de la vienne chargée des
personnes âgées des personnes
handicapées
michel billé qui est sociologue c'est
l'auteur du dictionnaire impertinent de
la vieillesse et damien le guay qui est
philosophe qui vient de publier quand
lutte l'euthanasie sera là l'ordre est
qu'on s'arrête un moment sur le cas des
ehpad privé ce qu'on connaît le mieux
puisque c'est ce dont tout le monde
parle depuis la parution du livre les
fossoyeurs de victor castanet pourquoi y
at-il un secteur privé qui représente à
peu près un quart du marché des maisons
de retraite en france 24 % exactement
pourquoi y at-il un secteur privé
puisqu'il est financé par le public mais
lui et à but commercial
libre de pratiquer n'importe quel tarif
c'est pas comme dans les hôtels où il ya
les 5 étoiles et 4 étoiles l'étroite
étoiles là où vous pouvez décider que
vous êtes un cinq étoiles dans votre
tête et puis mettre des tarifs de 5
étoiles si vous en avez envie il ya très
peu de contrôles on le sait sont très
rares et ça peut être très lucratif pour
les actionnaires donc on peut être tenté
comme il semble que serait été le cas
chez rpa de rationner les soins la
nourriture
les postes les emplois et de façon à
augmenter sa marge de profit est
évidemment pourquoi y at-il un secteur
privé alors tout simplement parce que en
fait les pouvoirs publics enfin le
secteur public et le secteur associatif
à un moment ne pouvait pas répondre à
aux besoins en fait du vieillissement de
la population et donc le marché s'est
ouvert au secteur privé ce qui a permis
en fait de construire des ehpad un peu
plus luxueux si je puis dire que ce qui
était le cas dans le secteur public ce
qui était plutôt une bonne chose a
priori le problème c'est qu'en effet
c'est devenu un marché très lucratif et
que
parce qu'on manque de place aussi est-ce
qu'on manque de place
donc le les les investisseurs privés ont
ils les moyens voilà de construire des
établissements parce qu'il en manquait
donc on a ouvert le marché et le
problème comme je dis donc c'est devenu
un secteur très lucratif
et donc ce qui se pose c'est que
finalement au lieu de prendre en charge
dans certains grands groupes les
résidents en fait on cherche à faire du
profit avant tout et c'est ça le voilà
ce qui est dénoncé dans le livre les
fossoyeurs c'est à dire que le principal
intérêt de certains grands groupes c'est
de dégager le maximum de bénéfices en
rationnant oui mais on en revient
toujours à la même chose à partir du
moment où c'est nous qui finançons on
peut se dire mais attendez pourquoi
est-ce qu'on pourquoi est-ce qu'on est
si tolérant avec les tarifs
l'encadrement et les bénéfices qu'on
l'ait d'après ce que tout le monde dit
ouais mais la question c'est ça la
question c'est le manque de contrôle en
fait de ce secteur privé lucratif c'est
à dire qu'il faudrait augmenter les
contrôles
et
interdire en fait c'est ces dérapages
enfin ces dysfonctionnements c'est
qu'ils sont insupportables et donc là
c'est un problème justement de contrôler
directement lié à l'êta alors avant de
se demander s'il faut raser tous les
ehpad faut-il nationaliser les ehpad
privé michel billé au personnellement
cela
pas de peine c'est clair mais je ne sais
pas si pour autant il faut tout
nationaliser
combien rapporte
le placement le plus courant des frais
que font les dons concitoyens le livret
a voilà combien les balles et on limite
le rendement des ehpad ou au rapport du
livret a et bien vous allez voir que
d'un seul coup il ya des choses qui vont
qu'ils vont se transformer qui vont ce
qu'ils ont changé mais il me semble le
croire - d'investisseurs aussi et est
donc moins de places d'ehpad or c'est
justement ce qui est censé résoudre le
secteur primé d'après ce que j'ai
compris il n'y a pas ces places qu'on a
qu'on demande aux investisseurs privés
première mais c'est pareil pour eux on
connaît ça depuis longtemps pour
l'hôpital c'est parce qu'on manque de
place à l'hôpital que l'on a développé
les cliniques privées alors dont il
convient de ne jamais dire privé à but
lucratif n'empêche qu'elles sont privées
à but lucratif évidemment c'est il me
semble que
vraiment j'ai parlé au tout début de
notre de nos échanges j'ai parlé d'
idéologie j'ai fait exprès il me semble
que nous sommes vraiment prisonnier
d'une idéologie libérale qui nous fait
croire que que l'investissement privé
peut faire faire des économies au public
eh ben c'est simplement une illusion
évidemment bien sûr c'est faux nom le
l'investissement privé ne fait pas faire
de d'économie au public pas du tout
voilà mais nous sommes toujours prêts à
le croire évidemment je ne me souviens
pas d'avoir entendu des clients enfin
des patients plus et great en clinique
privée sortir de là scandalisé en dix
ans on a essayé de me rationné la
nourriture les soins le personnel etc ça
n'est pas le cas dans les cliniques
privées on sait qu'il peut y avoir
des manques par rapport au service
public justement mais on sait aussi
qu'il ya un service il ya dix mètres
carrés il ya un confort qui n'existent
pas toujours dans le dans les services
publics là visiblement celle inverse
donc on peut se priver quand même la
question vous pensiez courbet oui mais
ce qui est terrible c'est que pour
pallier à ce manque dans le service
public on est en train de privatiser le
service public c'est à dire que vous
fait hospitaliser dentelle chu et c est
vous êtes accueillis dans l'entrée même
du chu vous êtes accueillis par une
entreprise privée qui vient
prendre dit différents renseignements
sur vous pour savoir si finalement vous
allez accéder à une chambre seul ou pas
et si vous avez le téléphone ou pas et
combien vous allez le payer et combien
qu'est ce que c'est que ce cirque eux la
enfin non l'hôpital public devrait
rester publique et bien les pales
devrait rester ehpad tous les jours ou
presque je reçois sur ma boîte mail d d
invitation à investir dans l'ehpad voilà
fait un placement dans l'épave mais
demain je ferai l'objet d'un placement
dans l'ehpad ça suffit ces histoires
c'est effrayant non je veux pas aller
faire de placement en ehpad mais demain
je ne veux pas que l'on me places en
ehpad je demande en revanche à un ehpad
de m'accueillir éventuellement parce que
je serais peut-être très content d'en
trouver un je demande d'y être accueilli
certainement pas placer alors c'est vrai
qu'on retrouve toujours sur internet
d'ailleurs des on vous appelle à placer
votre argent dans les ehpad et est par
exemple dans le groupe orpea voilà
et on nous fait croire que ça va
rapporter beaucoup et ça rapporte
beaucoup donc évidemment les gossip nos
concitoyens y vont mais mais on voit
bien que là on est sur une démarche ah
oui je sais idéologique vraiment valérie
d'auge faut supprimer les le secteur
privé dans les ehpad nationaliser ce qui
qui existait et on faire des
établissements publics
non je ne suis pas favorable la
nationalisation des ehpad alors en ce
qui concerne le département de la vienne
c'est vrai qu'on a eu un certain nombre
d'établissements et résidences services
à l'époque qui étaient gérés par les
communes est en très grande difficulté
financière et on a été content de
trouver ces grands groupes qui avaient
des moyens financiers importants pour
pour reprendre ces établissements qui
était qui était un petit peu mis de la
malle
vous parliez tout à l'heure de contrôler
conjointement avec l'agencé régionale de
santé et le département il nous faisons
des contrôles fréquents avec des
recommandations et surtout ensuite des
obligations dans le cas où c'était où
c'est vraiment nécessaire et moi ce que
je dirai ce qui serait important c'est
de proposer à ces groupes de réinvestir
ces capitaux sur de réinvestir les
bénéfices dans la structure même je
voudrais qu'on les contraignent à ça oui
enfin si vous leur expliquez vous ils
doivent mettre leur argent ça peut être
compliqué damien le guay
lambin jeu j'ai entendu monsieur billets
avec un peu d'étonnement jeu
l'idée qu'on puisse sacralisé si vous
voulez le service public est considéré
que l'état gère bien les finances si
c'était le cas ça ce serait mais on est
face à un état qui est à la fois obèses
gargantuesque impuissants et incapables
de s'autogérer pour arriver aux
meilleurs pourquoi est ce qu'on a fait
appel si j'ai bien compris aux ehpad
privé c'est que dans les années 2000 par
manque de ressources par manque d'argent
l'état fait appel aux services privés
pour effectivement
faire en sorte que les que les
établissements qui étaient dans un état
calamiteux cuisine façon d'une autre
revenir à un état normal un état
acceptable
première chose deuxième chose j'ai cité
effectivement le défenseur des droits un
depuis plusieurs années neuf mille
réclamations 50% sont deux secteurs
publics donc il faut croire que le
secteur public ne gère pas mieux
que le que le que le secteur privé 30%
pour les ehpad non lucratif et 20% pour
le privé donc ça veut dire que la
maltraitance institutionnelle dont on
parle elle n'est pas réservée aux seuls
établissements privés troisième point on
dit c'est extrêmement lucratif bon ben
j'ai regardé orpea ils font 3 milliards
9 de chiffre d'affaires 3 milliards note
de chiffre d'affaires et ils font 160
millions de résultat sont 4 5% de
résultat net et il distribue 58 millions
je veux dire c'est pas extrêmement
lucratif ce qui est extrêmement lucratif
et ce qui est intéressant pour ce groupe
là c'est la partie effectivement
immobilier parce qu'ils sont obligés
d'acheter cher paris s'est laissé aller
à avoir des prix de l'immobilier
absolument dingue donc effectivement ils
sont obligés d'investir quand ils
veulent se développer sur l'immobilier
est ce qu'on peut trouver un moyen entre
l'état pur pour cela bon donc je trouve
que là aussi
7 7 matches cette façon de se défausser
de la part de l'état sur le secteur
privé pour régler des problèmes qu'il
n'arrive pas à régler d'une part
deuxièmement derrière pour ne pas
organiser le rapport libos dit et qu'il
appelait un pilotage de la qualité et
non des process que la hs devait établir
un certificat pour être directeur des
tic des ehpad et ça n'a pas été fait
exc quand j'ai un moment donné faut
quand même se sont arrêtés de 2,2 de
considérer que le secteur privé en tant
que tel parce que privé parce que
faisant des résultats serait le loreur d
abomination et que l'état serait
vertueux non malheureusement réforme de
l'état que l'on attend depuis depuis
vingt ans ne se fait pas et on se
trouvent dans des situations qui sont
malheureusement les situations que nous
constatons aujourd'hui et qui se
répercute sur la maltraitance dans les
étapes dans les ehpad pardon et que nous
constatons là on l'a dans le sujet qui
nous concerne aujourd'hui les lise
richard but qui avait enquêté pendant
trois ans dans les ehpad il ya quoi
comme différence entre public et le
privé dans le privé c'est vrai que les
établissements je les dis sont beaucoup
plus luxueux plus confortable et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui c'est en fait ce qui
attire en fait les familles de place et
enfin de mettre leurs parents justement
dans ces établissements parce que
l'apparence l'apparence est belle mais
en termes d'accompagnement on le disait
l'accompagnement n'est pas meilleure
dans le privé lucratif est moins
nombreux et moins nombreux il ya moins
de personnel dans le privé lucratif que
dans les ehpad publics et public
hospitalier
donc c'est vrai que l'intérêt du privé
c'est effectivement de proposer des
établissements des chambres qui sont
plus confortables mais en termes
d'accompagnement humain et c'est quand
même ce qui prime il faut le rappeler
pour les personnes âgées qui sont des
personnes qui ont besoin mais voilà
qu'on s'occupe d'elle qui ont besoin
d'être rassurés elles ont plus besoin de
personnel que d'une belle chambre si je
puis dire même si enfin l'un ne va pas
sans l'autre et évidemment qu'il faut
rénover et établissements publics qui se
détériore
donc je pense que en effet on ne peut
pas forcément se passer du privé du
secteur privé lucratif mais il faut
accentuer les contrôles pour empêcher
justement ces dérives et augmenter les
moyens humains dans tous les
établissements qu'ils soient publics
associatifs ou privés
michel billé vouliez rajouter quelque
chose
des personnels
nombreux formés compétents
bienveillant qualifié reconnu
reconnu et là effectivement en avant
sera bien sûr que l'établissement soit
public ou privé est jeune je ne suis pas
comment dire je ne suis pas en
opposition avec ce qui ce que disait
damien le guay jeu je pense simplement
que
à chaque fois qu'on nous a fait croire
que le public
ne pourrait pas faire les choses on a
renoncé à prendre soin d'eux des
personnes âgées accueillis dans
l'établissement etc il semble que il il
nous faut absolument
maintenir ce cap alors on dit on va
multiplier les contrôles moi je d'accord
multipliant les contrôles je veux bien
encore faut-il que les ars et même les
services départementaux et les moyens de
mettre en oeuvre les contrôles parce que
ça suppose pour faire aller faire un
contrôle dans un ehpad ça suppose du
personnel compétent forme est disponible
qu'ils puissent se déplacer etc eh ben
les ars aujourd'hui je ne suis pas sûr
qu'elle dispose de beaucoup de personnel
disponible donc vraiment je crois qu'il
y à un investissement et je ré emploie
ce terme exprès un investissement très
important à faire à tous les niveaux de
notre système si c'est vrai que nous
souhaitons demain que nos contemporains
les plus âgées puissent être accueillis
dans des ehpad dignes de ceux qu'ils
sont censés accueillir les rideaux
j'avais les moyens de faire des
contrôles efficaces régulier
compétents
on le fait déjà on le fait déjà depuis
de nombreuses années alors à réception
de plaintes et pas seulement on va
régulièrement dans les structures
voir ce qui s'y passe
qui nous rendent des comptes après nous
sommes financeurs et ils doivent nous
rendre compte oui nous le faisons assez
régulièrement alors battant la question
que je me posais dès le début de cette
émission c'est faut-il raser les ehpad
donc on sait bien ce que c'est que
l'alternative alors vous pourrez re
fonder un nouveau système puisque celui
ci a l'air de mal fonctionner
on pourrait laisser les gens à leur
domicile vous avez enquêté aussi chose
en ce domaine ça a pas l'air de très
bien fonctionner non plus
et puis après il ya l'autre il ya ce que
nous redoutons tous c'est l'euthanasie
c'est à dire que tout à coup on se dit
ça après tout il faut pas que les gens
vivent si vieux et parfois on s'en fiche
tellement des gens les plus âgés qu'on
pourrait aussi les laisser mourir
l'euthanasie est temps dans ma bouche
évidemment symbolique
domicile oui c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup des et palmer à domicile c'est
pas forcément mieux il faut le dire il
ya aussi des problèmes de manque de
temps rencontré par les auxiliaires de
vie et les aide à domicile parce
qu'elles ont des emplois du temps très
limité c'est à dire qu'elles ont souvent
une heure pour intervenir chez une
personne âgée leur donner à manger
préparer le repas
nettoyer l'appartement et c'est donc
dans des temps très limité avec beaucoup
de déplacements etc donc c'est des
métiers qui sont aussi ça suffit dans ce
parking ça c'est financé principalement
par les départements
et donc il ya aussi énormément de
problème donc de manque de personnel
entre guillemets enfin en tout cas de
manque de temps au niveau des aides à
domicile ça crée de la frustration pour
les aides à domicile et ça crée aussi
cette maltraitance institutionnelle
auprès des personnes âgées
donc le domicile n'est pas forcément la
solution en tout cas il faut aussi
augmenter les moyens à domicile et pas
seulement dans les ehpad
et il ya aussi certaines situations ou
l'ehpad reste parfois la meilleure
solution c'est à dire qu' il ya des dca
enfin voilà où quand on est très en
dedans une perte d'autonomie très
importante qu'on a besoin d'une
surveillance 24 heures sur 24
le maintien à domicile n'est pas
forcément une solution et dans ces cas
là il vaut mieux aller dans un ehpad
après ce qu'il faut c'est encore une
fois changé le modèle des ehpad c'est à
dire que il faut les ouvrir sur
l'extérieur il faut cesser de les
construire justement en périphérie à
l'écart des villes ce qui augmente
justement ce qu'on disait le fait de
deux de ne plus s'intéresser aux
personnes âgées faut qu'elle puisse
rester vraiment des citoyens à part
entière pouvoir voilà se rendre dans la
cité où que la cité viennent à elle donc
il faut changer aussi le modèle des
ehpad et puis il faut aussi multiplier
les les solutions alternatives entre le
domicile et les ehpad il ya tout un tas
d'autres solutions qui existent
aujourd'hui mais qui sont encore trop
marginal donc il ya les habitats
alternatifs donc des colocations entre
personnes âgées voilà qui vont être à
peu près une dizaine et qui vont pouvoir
bénéficier d'un accompagnement avec des
auxiliaires de vie qui vivent sur place
donc la présidence comme ça oui c'est
des résidences mais donc là c'est
vraiment un système voilà d'habitat
alternatif qui se développe et qui est
très intéressant qui peut être une
solution pour des personnes âgées en
perte d'autonomie qui sont pas encore
vraiment très très très dépendantes mais
qui ont quand même besoin d'un
accompagnement quotidien il ya aussi un
système de familles d'accueil justement
qui existent mais encore qui a encore
trop peu développée parce que métier
donc de famille d'accueil c'est aussi un
métier compliqué parce que c'est sept
jours sur sept 24 heures sur 24 donc il
ya aussi des améliorations à revoir
justement dans dans ce type d'accueil
mais ça peut être aussi une solution
intéressante parce qu'on va avoir un
accompagnement justement beaucoup plus
personnalisé que dans un ehpad
donc pour moi voilà je pense qu'il faut
clairement raser les ehpad je pense que
ce serait une hérésie il faut peut-être
limiter leur construction les changer le
modèle multiplier les offres
alternatives est augmenté également les
les moyens mais à domicile damien le
guay
mais vous avez deux choses différentes
la première c'est que toute cette
génération qui est maintenant dans les
ehpad ce sont des générations qui ont
énormément cotisé avec le système de la
répartition il se retrouve aujourd'hui
en situation où ils doivent en plus
payer
considérant que les générations à venir
ne sont pas assez nombreuses en termes
de nombre pour payer toutes les charges
que ça suppose donc sa première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que il me semble
que le débat actuel qui est
effectivement indispensable d'avoir met
en évidence et c'est comme quelque chose
qui est préjudiciable aux personnes
âgées le coup ça coûte aux familles ça
coûte à société ça coûtera encore plus
est pour des résultats qui sont pas
toujours à la hauteur la question c'est
quel est le message que nous faisons
passer auprès des personnes âgées sinon
que je reprends le terme que vous avez
employé parce que c'est l'objet de mon
livre c'est qu'en plus c'est le sujet
que vous les traitez sinon
qu'effectivement ces personnes là sont
en trop sont un peu en trop sont à la
marge son sont un peu considérés comme
des laissés pour compte et donc quel
traitement ou comment est ce que ces
personnes là sont susceptibles de
pouvoir intégrer le regard que la
société que l'état que le débat que
l'argent que cela suppose auprès de
leurs propres familles que tout cela
fait peser sur elle et sur la légitimité
la légitimité de leur présence au sein
de la société d'où effectivement la
question qui se pose à mon avis qui est
celle de savoir si derrière la question
de l'euthanasie dont vous avez parlé et
qui élevé de moyens mais derrière
l'euthanasie liberté ne se profile pas à
l'horizon la question de l'euthanasie et
kodlick et je renvoie à un set ce film
magnifique la ballade de narayama qui
suppose que à un moment donné on peut
considérer on va pouvoir considérer on
essuie ses petit malheureusement de
pouvoir considérer
que les personnes d'un certain âge sont
tellement à la charge de la société qu'
il faut qu'elles choisissent une façon
de ne plus exister ou de choisir une
solution qui leur permettrait à terme de
ne pas peser comme elle le comme elle
pèse aujourd'hui sur sur les finances et
sur la société dans son ensemble donc ça
c'est une vraie question à terme qu'il
importe de se poser parce que
effectivement tous les débats et tout ce
que l'état ne fait pas et tous les
problèmes qui ne sont pas posées
rejaillissent aussi sur la légitimité
de ces personnes âgées très vite valérie
d'auge
oui très vite vous dire que on a nous
sur le département de la vienne la dmr
qui intervient au domicile des familles
qui met à disposition des véhicules de
fonction pour leurs salariés on dispose
également d'habitat inclusif ce qui est
important d'avoir ces un panel d'offres
en fonction du reste à charge pour
limiter le reste à charge des résidents
et
tout en tenant compte du degré
d'autonomie il faut pas oublier que la
médecine a bien progressé la personne
âgée est souvent en forme mais c'est les
dents à côté qui est bien usé est
souvent mis à mal et avec des problèmes
de santé donc la solution de l'ehpad est
très bien mais je pense qu'il faut une
offre très complémentaires pour les
usagers en fonction de leurs goûts aussi
et de la halle du lieu où ils ont habité
sans les déracinés
michel billé
alors
développer le service à domicile oh là
là oui vraiment vraiment et il faut là
aussi former le personnel bien sûr c'est
très clair et ça coûtera un peu d'argent
tant mieux pour moi vraiment
oui à la diversification des réponses
oui nous aurons besoin de réponses qui
auront des formes multiples et pourquoi
pas la colocation etc oui bien sûr il me
semble que
il nous faut cependant être très
attentif à quelque chose j'ai déjà vu
arriver des publicités des slogans
promu notamment par des des des
gestionnaires privés à but lucratif d
pad qui nous disent les pas à domicile
non de grâce vous n'avez pas été foutu
de faire de votre ehpad mon domicile
vous allez pas maintenant prétendre
venir faire de mon domicile votre ehpad
donc non vous ne viendrez pas à domicile
faire de mon domicile votre ehpad et ça
commence toujours avec les mêmes choses
c'est à dire on va vous installez un
digicode et une caméra de surveillance
comme ça toute manière allez stop non
les compétences de l'ehpad à l'extérieur
de l'ehpad louis ouverture réinventant
l'ehpad un ehpad ouvert sur le monde
dans lequel le monde puisse rentrer et
un ehpad doux résidents et personnel
puisse sortir parce que oui nous avons à
domicile besoin des mêmes compétences
oui aucun doute et puis j'ajouterai si
par hasard enfin par hasard
pourquoi est-ce que j'emploie cette
expression si de fait
la crise que nous connaissons
produisaient pour effet de banaliser
l'euthanasie
je trouverais que vraiment la crise en
question nous nous aurait fait atteindre
une situation absolument dramatique je
ne sais pas assez dit s'il y avait
derrière des intentions d mais il n'est
pas à mes yeux pensable
que l'euthanasie devienne un jour une
réponse
à la situation
de ceux qui ont
pour seul tort d'être né un peu avant
les autres je vous remercie tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
encore merci
merci
également au revoir